I think in another interview you said
you you run a tight ship on set I do
it's great yeah
what are five things the director needs
to do when they first get on set okay
so are you referring to just the as a
director are you talking about a
director producer let's try a director
producer okay because that's what I do
I've never had the luxury of just being
director that's why I have to ask that
question because being a producer you're
worried about money from day one so what
I do is I make sure that everybody's on
time I'm I am very I'm extremely tough
about that I fired people cuz they
arrive late straight up just because you
know you have a key that is late and you
have ten people standing around even at
their 15 minutes late ten people times
fifteen you know is basically an hour
and two and a half hours of time you've
lost when you're dealing with minuscule
budgets that kind of stuff adds up very
quickly and that means money lost so I
take that stuff extremely seriously I
rehearsed my actors I know what I want
I don't vacillate onset I know what I
need to cover because I'm thinking about
the Edit I shoot for the edit and then I
give some freedom I'm very much a
stickler upon my script very much so I
don't really allow much improv because
again it comes down to budget you know
with the webseries we let a lot of
improv jokes we had a different budget
structure for that then we did for the
feature film but that the one thing that
I do too is I try and make breakfast for
everybody just because one is it puts me
in the mindset of what I need to do for
the day just by the repetition of doing
things also too as a matter of welcoming
people to the set that day and then also
the idea of if you go into later hours
people generally a little bit more
friendlier because they know you fed
them
I know it sounds crazy that's not why I
do but I've learned that's that's a
benefit of it
and it's just something that like you
know in my early career I worked in the
FMB business Wells and making films and
stuff which I strongly suggest anybody
doing
I think somebody that works in the
restaurant business is a great proving
ground for great filmmakers especially
producers just because you have to think
about a lot of different things and I'd
get into that whole or topic but um I
make sure everything's buttoned up but
make sure that we have call sheets that
make sure that everybody that I have a
shot lists for everybody I'm just I'm
very organized in fact it's funny
because my wife always says like I wish
you ran the rest of your life like
you're writing your productions
you know because everything inhabits
place everything's very specific you
know it's not to say that that that like
you know my my sets are dismal to be on
that's all I'm saying at all but I just
need that that you know uniformity so
that we can rest here so I know that
everything's being taken care of because
when you're producing and directing
you're doing a lot of internal battles
in your head because like you know like
I didn't get that shot I need to
take it again but then you're losing
light and you realize that oh my gosh I
gotta like this thing it's gonna we're
gonna we're gonna run over overtime and
so now all of a sudden like I'm doing
the math in my head and be like oh wow
like is it worth it you know
and so you have these little battles in
your head if you're a director producer
you know I always like also make sure I
surround myself with like you know
go-getter like you know
Ryan is just he's a beast he just dug in
early on it just got stuff done for me
assuming a lot of responsibility you
know and my entire team it's a matter of
like everybody understanding what the
vision is and and getting everybody to
follow that vision my DP Matt you know
it just it just it's interesting you
know every every film set has their own
battle scars
and big questions would you go to battle
again with those people that's the
biggest question you have to ask after a
shoot and I've gone to battle with
people many times
itself well how is working in a
restaurant preparing you for a film set
oh so many things so as a waitron yet
think fast on your feet you know so I
have to realize that you know you're
constantly pleasing people you have to
remember a lot of things you know what
you carry out of the kitchen you should
be carrying something back so it's a
matter of efficiency if you're really
good to the if you work your butt off
and you're good the owner the owner
might even cater your your film shoot
you know you get a generally a meal a
day as well so that means that you only
have to provide yourself two meals you
know there's the idea of camaraderie in
a matter of like you know getting
through something that's very hectic
because most restaurants are very had to
get at least at some point of of a shift
it's a matter of working in or feet for
long hours and you also have to stay
very organized as well in terms of
recommending in your head of what has to
come next there's a lot of things
working in the restaurant business it's
funny because like I always tell
everybody the other thing to a better of
like working the restaurant business
like you can do your film business stuff
during the day and then work at night
which is which is what I did early out
of my career and then what I would end
up doing is take off or you know six
weeks to shoot my film you know and they
always would take me back so with a hard
worker in things but you know that's
kind of like how I got through my early
career
you